[Music]  this palace located in the remote hills  of eastern turkey has been steadily  built by one family for generations  spanning over a century  [Music]  ishkapasha palace is the last remaining  monument of the ottoman empire in turkey  construction began in 1685 by kolak abdi  pasha and was continued by his son and  then his grandson  [Music]  it combines a variety of architectural  styles including armenian georgian and  ottoman elements  the palace also includes middle eastern  inspired features such as arches and  domes  the ishkap pasha palace is such a  cultural icon that it was featured on  the turkish 100 lira banknote between  2005 and 2009.  the palace was abandoned with the fall  of the ottoman empire but today the site  is a protected historical landmark  [Music]  you